THIS WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL
WITH THIS MEMO?
IF TRUMP IS GUILTY, IF TRUMP
DID ALL THIS, WHY ARE THEY
WORRIED ABOUT A MEMO
DETAILING HOW THEY DID IT?
IF TRUMP DID IT, IF TRUMP
COLLUDED, IF TRUMP DID ALL
THIS HORRIBLE STUFF AND
CARTER PAGE DID ALL OF THIS
HORRIBLE STUFF.
IF STEVEN MILLER DID -- IF
MELANIA TRUMP DID ALL OF
THIS HORRIBLE STUFF.
IF DONALD TRUMP JR. OR ERIC
TRUMP OR BARRON TRUMP DID
ALL OF THIS HORRIBLE STUFF,
WHY IN THE WORLD IS THE FBI
SO AFRAID OF FINDING OUT HOW
THEY DONE IT?
WHY IS THE FBI, WHY THE
SO, CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THEY
GOT THERE?
I HAVE GONE THROUGH AS MUCH
AS OF THIS AS I CAN ABSORB
BEFORE IT ALL STARTS TO TURN
AND I CAN'T FIND ANY GOOD
REASONS TO NOT DISCLOSE THIS
MEMO.
>> Sean: WHEN I DO RADIO,
FAR AWAY.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE IS SO
NUMBER ONE.
I DON'T KNOW.
JASON CHAFFETZ AND TOM
FITTON.
OKAY, I THINK THIS IS WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO GET
TOMORROW.
THIS IS WHY THEY DON'T WANT
IT, THE PHONY CLINTON BOUGHT
PROPAGANDA, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YEAH, I THINK WE ARE ALSO
GOING TO START TO SEAT
FINANCIAL TRAIL WHO WAS
PAYING FOR IT HOW IT WAS
FINANCED.
WHO WAS MOVING IT ALONG.
I'M WORRIED THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY BROADER THAN JUST
THE FBI.
THIS WAS THE CHIEF AT
COUNTER ESPIONAGE.
HE WAS THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE.
IS HE USING A NON-SECURITY
PHONE TO SEND 50,000 TEXT
MESSAGES TO HIS LOVER WHO IS
HAVING AN AFFAIR WITH YOU
DON'T THINK THE RUSSIANS,
THE CHINESE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE.
THE RUSSIANS, THE CHINESE
AND EVERYBODY ELSE DON'T
ALREADY KNOW ABOUT IT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE ACTUALLY THE LAST ONES TO
HEAR ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: THE IRONY OF
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA IN THE
END.
AND THEN THAT USED TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON HER
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE IN AN
ELECTION YEAR, TOM FITTON,
YOU DEAL WITH GOVERNMENT
CORRUPTION ALL THE TIME.
EVER DEAL WITH ANYTHING THIS
BIG?
>> NO.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR 2
20 YEARS AT JUDICIAL WATCH.
I SAW THE FBI FILES GO OVER
TO THE CLINTON WHITE HOUSE.
THE CHINESE GENERALS GO INTO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT NEVER DID WE SEE THE
POWERS OF GOVERNMENT BEING
USED TO SPY IN A POLITICAL
FOR, THIS HER CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE ALSO HELPED PAY
FOR THIS DOSSIER WHICH WAS
USED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION.
SO YOU HAVE GOT A DEMOCRATIC
PARTY UPSET ABOUT NEWS OR
PRESIDENT-ELECT DIRECT
PRIVATE MEETING, DID HE TELL
THE PRESIDENT THAT IT HAD
BEEN PAID FOR BY HILLARY
CLINTON?
REMEMBER THAT PRECIPITATED
WHO, BY ALL ACCOUNTS, IS
STILL USING THIS DOSSIER TO
TARGET TRUMP WORLD.
>> Sean: AT THE END OF THE
WITHOUT ALL OF THESE EVENTS
OR THE FACT THAT IF THE FBI
AND COMEY, AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT, WANTED TO EVEN HIRE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND PAY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
WE'LL LEARN MORE ABOUT THAT,
TOO.
AND DID ROD ROSENSTEIN
EXPAND THE FISA WARRANT?
IT SEEMS SO CORRUPT AND
INCESTUOUS TO ME AT THIS
POINT HOW DO WE POSSIBLY
MAKE THIS RIGHT?
>> WELL, ONLY SUNLIGHT IS
GOING TO MAKE IT BETTER.
ONLY EXPOSING IT I FIND IT
CURIOUS THAT THE FBI IS
SAYING, PLEASE, DON'T
RELEASE THE NAMES.
DON'T RELEASE THE NAMES.
WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE
WRONG.
THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW YOU HIGHLIGHT THE
ACCOUNTABLE ON THIS.
AND FILL IN EVEN MORE.
ONLY GIVE YOU FOUR PAGES
TOO.
>> Sean: WE ONLY HAD 20
SECONDS.
YOU WILL
GAU WILL
GAVEWILL
GAVE HLL
GAVE HER A PASS SO SHE COULD
STAY IN THE RACE TRUE OR
FALSE.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS
ARE WE GOING TO GET THE
UNMASKING?
THIS IS ONE BATTLE THAT
NEEDS TO BE FOUGHT FOR FULL
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THIS